In the last three weeks, my ankles are swollen.
They are better in the morning.
Is it because of the kidneys?
I heard too much sodium, potassium, and phosphorus could do that.
Yeah, so getting, you know, CBC in a complete metabolic panel,
you could look at that and see if your electrolytes
are on a balance.
So any kind of imbalance in electrolytes can affect
the retention of fluid.
So your kidneys have stimulation by the forebode
boosted in your pancreas that stimulates the uptake of fluid
and the release of fluid.
So if you have, you know, too much fluid that is being retained
and it's not being excreted by your kidneys,
that you could have an increase fluid in your extremities
or elsewhere.
Can be other reasons for that too.
You know, something as simple as posture while you're sleeping.
But they're better in the morning.
It would be something as simple as posture while you're sitting.
So if people are sitting at a desk all day
or people that aren't moving or people that are standing
on their feet all day, it's really not a kidney function
that they're getting fluid in their lower extremities.
It's a heart issue.
So as far as moving fluid out of the tissues
and into the limb system, it's a function of muscular contraction.
But as far as pumping blood back from your lower extremities,
that's a function of your heart.
So somebody with congestive heart failure,
weakening of the heart, weakening of the strength
of the heart contraction is going to have, you know,
an excess fluid in their extremities,
especially lower extremities.
So making sure you're moving,
you're sitting at a desk all day,
you're moving your toes, moving your feet,
writing an alphabet, let's your feet,
all these different lymphatic things
that we have written on some blogs.
So it's not always a chemical issue
and it can be a postural, can be hard to get.
There's a lot of different possibilities.